[Applaudissements]
il voit là et il m'a laissé avec mes
trois points en moins
donc ça j'aurais peut-être dû à partager
cela ne s'est pas assez drôle c'est
archi jean jésus bienvenue mais voilà on
le sait la vérité c'est tout moi c'est
quand même j'ai inventé un truc non
quand j'ai tué quelqu'un allait lui
sinon c'est tout et c'est bon ou non
mais voilà c'est le meilleur
par exemple vous avez tout à l'heure en
revanche vous il était de face et qu'il
est dans la maison de campagne est lié
aux délais qui nous accueillent était un
beau [ __ ] cyril ce genre d'attitude
alors qu'on est invité
c'est que on le plaisir de venir avec
des gens je trouve ça minable dont on ne
connaît pas et on n'est pas loin du buzz
et ça a pesé
c'était et le quelle est pour vous la
dit matters télé je sais qu'ils vous
embêter le plus aux [ __ ] après la
bouée appart avec dechavanne et dit
qu'elle est l'endroit le plus insolite
vous avez fait l'amour dans matthieu
delormeau renault
[Applaudissements]